so
the time
the year 1881
the place
the general hospital in the city of
vienna austria
theodore billrock
teacher of medicine
pioneer surgeon
event
so important that medical history
records it as the beginning of a new era
the
problem to attempt to cure for a disease
as old as humanity
the patient
teresa heller
admitted to the hospital four days ago
symptoms
gastric pain for three months
her diet
a few spoonfuls of sour milk daily
pulse
thready
evening temperature
38.2 santa grade
diagnosis carcinoma of the pylorus
up to this time no malignant tumor of
the stomach had ever been successfully
removed
the hazards attending such an operation
were many
the ever-present threat of infection
the possibility of surgical shock
the dangers of prolonged anesthesia
the knowledge that others had failed
but pitted against this was bill roth's
conviction that this was an early legion
an operable case
that his years of research could now be
applied to the aid of a human being
complete removal of the diseased tissue
was the only way to prevent this
patient's certain death
but removal of the cancer was not enough
a safe and adequate repair was of equal
importance
as history now knows this operation the
bill roth 1 was a success
more than any other fact it proved the
importance of early diagnosis
followed by prompt adequate treatment
today gastric cancer is still a serious
medical responsibility
today as in bill roth's day
surgery offers to the patient the only
hope of cure
however thanks to the great technical
and intellectual progress achieved in
all branches of medical science the
management of the cancer patient is
vastly improved
the surgeon today as did bill roth
intervenes in gastric cancer in the hope
that the disease is limited solely to
the stomach
with this in mind careful palpation of
known sites of spread and of the stomach
determines the extent of the disease in
these areas
radical resection of the momentum
together with wide clearance of the
lymph nodes is a routine measure to
remove all possible disease
in the bill roth tradition the pyloric
tumor can now be isolated by a safe
margin of the duodenal segment
similarly
the major portion of the gastric segment
will be sacrificed
in most of the modifications of the bill
roth operation
the duodenum is closed
and the reapproximation of the remaining
portion of the stomach with the small
intestine is established
the resultant anastomosis tension free
and airtight will permit the patient
normal dietary comfort with but slightly
modified dietary habit
thus the operation initiated by bill
roth more than 60 years ago
remains today the only treatment of
gastric cancer that offers any hope of
cure
of five major sites for malignant
neoplasms
cancer of the stomach has the third
highest incidence
however of the mortality averages for
these sites
the mortality of gastric cancer is among
the highest
this disease causes more than one-fourth
of all cancer deaths
the reason for this high mortality is
seen in the clinical behavior of cancer
of the stomach
although cancer may occur primarily in
any area of the stomach
more than three-fourths of these lesions
occur in the region of the pylorus
dispatcher or indigestion is the most
common first complaint
here as the cancer continues to grow
mechanical obstruction may take place
as a result of this growth
pain unrelated to food becomes evident
in addition there may be loss of
appetite vomiting and fatigue
it is in this stage of disease and
because of these symptoms that the
average patient sees his physician
at the time of surgical exploration
often delayed as much as several months
the disease is usually found to have
invaded the regional lymph nodes
however one third to one half of all
patients seen in this stage are still
candidates for resection
nevertheless despite radical resection
the tragic factor of delay permits local
recurrence of disease
together with distant metastases which
result in the deaths within five years
of three-fourths of these patients
these deaths added to all other gastric
cancer deaths account for the dark
overall picture of gastric cancer
any appreciable reduction of this
mortality requires that cancer be
suspected while it is still confined
entirely to the stomach
unfortunately this clinically young
lesion provides little evidence upon
which to hang this suspicion either by
the patient himself or by his physician
as a rule the gastric cancer patient is
a mature adult with a complaint of vague
dispection whose tentative diagnosis is
gastric ulcer
in other cases the only early complaint
may be unexplained loss of weight
associated with some degree of secondary
anemia
and sometimes the symptoms may not be
suggestive of gastrointestinal disease
at all
in general a mass is not palpable in
early gastric cancer although these
symptoms chronic dispatcher with or
without pain anorexia weight loss
secondary anemia are suggestive of many
disorders
the most serious single disease which
may cause one or any of them
is cancer
therefore whenever this suspicion exists
the patient should be given the benefit
of a thorough examination
early suspicion
accurate diagnosis
effective treatment
by application of this triad of
management early stomach cancer can be
excised sufficiently to reduce the
likelihood of recurrence
the statistics in such cases of early
gastric cancer show a mortality decrease
of nearly half
a similar result can be achieved in
breast cancer
of the four quadrants of the breast the
upper outer quadrant is the usual sight
of cancer
regardless of sight however the behavior
of breast cancer is quite uniform
in its early stage this tumor like most
cancer develops silently
however as growth continues the
connective tissue is involved resulting
in flattening or dimpling of the skin
by the same process there is often
retraction of the nipple
in addition the regional nodes become
involved because of lymphatic spread
it is at this stage of disease that the
average patient is seen by her physician
the treatment permitting the greatest
chance for survival is a radical
mastectomy
however about three out of four patients
so treated will succumb within five
years
due to local recurrence and to distant
metastases to the supraclavicular nodes
the other breast
and to the lungs and bones
these cases
together with other breast cancer
fatalities result in this statistical
picture
any reduction of this mortality requires
that breast cancer be suspected while it
is confined entirely to the breast
the mass of early breast cancer however
may be interpreted as benign disease
palpation alone is not enough to
differentiate between a benign and a
malignant mass
of the breast in various positions may
be required before eliciting a
diagnostic sign of early cancer
this sign
skin retraction so consistent in
malignancy should call for an immediate
microscopic examination of suspected
tissue
a local excision and examination of all
breast tumors should be made in the
operating room
the excised mass is found to be
malignant
a radical mastectomy can be performed
immediately
except in rare cases a simple mastectomy
has no place in the surgery of breast
cancer
adequate flat development permits better
exposure of the operative field
this exposure makes possible thorough
removal of both pectoral muscles
removal of the pectoral muscles now
permits meticulous dissection of the
axilla
only by such radical dissection can
suspected areas of spread be included in
the removal of the breast itself
in a great majority of cases following
this operation the patient will have the
normal use of her arm
but what is vastly more important
the diseased breast has been excised
widely enough and early enough to
diminish the probability of recurrence
thus the mortality of early breast
cancer can be effectively reduced
cancer of the large bowel offers an
equal challenge in as much as nearly
half of these growths occur in the
rectum
of the rectum usually begins as a lesion
confined to the mucosa
as it grows however
ulceration of the mucosa takes place
producing intermittent rectal bleeding
at the same time mechanical venous
blocking may initiate hemorrhoids
a surprisingly large number of patients
are treated for hemorrhoids without any
investigation made to rule out the
possibility of underlying cancer
as further growth of the tumor takes
place
intra-luminal obstruction produces
constipation or diarrhea or both
alternately with the stools frequently
containing mucus and blood
it is with these symptoms and in this
stage of disease that the patient
generally sees his physician
an abdominal perineal resection offers
this patient the best opportunity for
survival
but here again the frequent delay of
treatment results in the recurrence of
disease both locally and distantly and
accounts for the deaths within five
years of more than three quarters of
these patients
these losses from recurrence together
with cases considered inoperable result
in the high mortality of rectal cancer
since more than half of rectal cancers
originate within reach of the examining
finger
here is the first and perhaps simplest
line of attack against this disease
if a rectal lesion is suspected or if
rectal symptoms are present
the patient should immediately be given
the benefit of a thorough examination
this should in addition to the digital
examination include practoscopy and
x-ray together with microscopic study of
tissue specimens
in the treatment of rectal cancer the
rectum is first approached through an
abdominal incision
this is necessary in order to free the
lower bowel a considerable segment of
which must be included in the resection
here again radical resection is a
requirement in order to ensure the
removal of all tissue which may
potentially be involved
the distal segment after being carefully
capped to prevent contamination is
tucked beneath the pelvic floor to be
removed through the perineum
the proximal segment is carried through
the abdominal wall to form a colostomy
patients may get along without soilage
and even without a colostomy bag
providing the bowel is irrigated
thoroughly at regular intervals
the perineal phase of the operation can
usually be undertaken immediately
careful dissection
much accomplished bluntly prevents
injury to the prostate and to the
seminal vesicles
extirpation of this disease is
accomplished by the complete removal of
the rectum
by such adequate surgery rectal cancer
can be treated so as to reduce the
likelihood of recurrence
the statistical picture of these early
cases rewards our efforts by showing a
mortality decrease of dramatic
proportions
the female genital tract is a frequent
side of cancer and of these lesions
about two-thirds occur in the cervix
in its early stage this lesion may be
misinterpreted as a benign condition
such as cervical erosion
as growth continues however lucaria
usually becomes evident or more
pronounced
and with ulceration of the cervical
mucosa spotting or frank bleeding may
occur
this bleeding in women of menopausal age
is often mistakenly viewed as a sign of
the change of life
further extensive growth may take place
without new symptoms being added
here again we have a typical picture
caused by delay which too frequently the
patient presents to her physician
radiation has been widely used in the
treatment of this disease
external radiation by high voltage x-ray
supplemented by intra-cavitary radium
therapy has sufficient effect upon these
lesions to permit the five-year survival
of one out of four of these patients
radiation therapy however is not the
only form of treatment
today modern surgery together with
improved pre and post-operative care
permits complete extirpation of the
disease with safety in selected cases
in addition the surgical approach allows
visualization
and the removal of the regional lymph
nodes
despite radical surgery despite
irradiation
most of these patients are seen too late
and again local recurrence of disease
lymphatic spread
and metastases cause the deaths within
five years of about three out of four
and so
the average five-year result
cervical cancer must and can be
suspected early
true this lesion may be masked by
leukoplakia or by cervical erosion
therefore the family physician should
take advantage of tissue biopsy in the
presence of any cervical abnormality
tissue biopsy is a diagnostic method of
proved accuracy
but on the other hand a perfectly normal
appearing cervix may mask underlying
early cancer
to determine the likelihood of such
occult disease the physician has at hand
the cytologic method of cancer detection
such cytologic tests followed by biopsy
examinations when indicated have an
encouragingly high incidence of accuracy
a pelvic examination including tissue or
cytologic studies should be made
routinely in all cases of vaginal
complaint if cervical cancer is to be
found early
and when such a routine study is found
suspicious of cancer the patient has the
benefit of immediate treatment
effective treatment by irradiation often
calls for massive x-ray dosage of the
entire pelvis
this is frequently supplemented by the
intra-cavitary application of radium or
in some instances radium may be the only
form of therapy
thus by adequate treatment whether
radiological or surgical
cancer of the cervix can be interrupted
early enough to minimize the danger of
recurrence
the statistical picture of early
cervical cancer shows a marked reduction
in five-year mortality
in recent years cancer of the lung has
been diagnosed with increased frequency
a major bronchus is the site of about
four-fifths of all lung cancer
the early growth of this tumor takes
place by submucosal extension
at this stage a pre-existing cough
becomes aggravated
mucus becomes manifest and may well be
stained with
blood this cough is altogether too
frequently interpreted by the patient or
by his position to be a cigarette cough
or the result of a cold
meanwhile because of the delay continued
growth of the tumor intra-luminally
results in bronchial obstruction and
resultant emphysema or atelectasis with
the likelihood of superimposed secondary
infection
extraluminally the cancer invades the
lung peripherally and extends toward the
pleura
this is the picture of disease which the
average patient presents at thoracotomy
about half of these patients considered
operable are candidates for
pneumonectomy
however the delay is to be reckoned with
in metastases to lymph nodes
such as peribronchial
paratracheal
mediastinal
and abdominal
together with blood-borne spread to the
other lung
to the bones and other organs
within five years
three-fourths of these treated patients
will be dead
because of this insidious clinical
behavior
lung cancer is one of our greatest
cancer problems
since early lung cancer provides little
or no sign of its presence
the detection of this disease by
clinical means is one of the physicians
most difficult tasks
on the other hand a chest x-ray may
provide a simple effective method of
disclosing lung cancer in its earlier
stages
such an x-ray should be made on all
cases with persistent cough
nor should the history of a cold or a
smoker's cough preclude the search for
underlying cancer
in recent years the advances of thoracic
surgery have made thoracotomy a safe
operative procedure
in some cases this technique may be the
only method of establishing the
diagnosis
careful palpation of the chest wall for
evidence of disease is the first step in
exploration
if no extension is found and the tumor
appears to be confined entirely to the
lung a pneumonectomy can offer this
patient a good chance of survival
closure of the bronchial stump is
carried out simultaneously with the
amputation of the bronchus
except in rare instances lobectomy has
no place in the surgery of lung cancer
only by total removal of the lung can
cancer of this organ be treated
effectively enough to dim the danger of
recurrence
the benefit in such early management is
fully worth the effort
mortality of average cases
all cases of these five sites is high
but in early cases
early suspicion
accurate diagnosis and effective
treatment have brought about marked
reductions in mortality
what is true of these five sites
is equally true of other sites of this
disease
our knowledge of cancer has grown
tremendously in recent years
and the quest for additional knowledge
is going on constantly in many fields of
study
in chemotherapy
hormones
radioactivity
carcinogenesis
virus research
genetics
and along numerous other avenues of
approach
in one day to come
the results of this ever increasing
knowledge
will lead us to the final answer to the
cancer problem
however
the immediate problem
the cancer patient today
must be answered here and now
and by the man who has always borne the
first responsibility for cancer
detection
the family position
you